[Music]
[Music]
you're collaborating with the one and
only Kelly Clarkson
I dare you how did that all happen so
what happened is that I got an email
from someone who's working at my label
and they were like Kelly's doing this
project she's singing a song in six
languages by the way that is insane
nobody's ever done that yeah one of the
languages was Arabic and they were like
are you up for being the one doing the
Arabic version and that was like of
course this is like this was such a huge
honor and I was so excited I couldn't
sleep that night I woke up the next day
worked with my parents on like
translating the lyrics I recorded it
sent it over and still to this day I
can't believe that I'm quite a project
with Kelly Clarkson because it's so
insane
you release a video that you meet at
home for a wickiup when it's over was
that the original plan or was it
supposed to be this big production or is
this something because of the ISIL
isolation that you did it at home so it
was because of the isolation that we
decided to do this at home the song was
very fitting with what's happening and I
was like it would be so cool to just
have a music video done at home it's
kind of just like a sneak peek into my
life cuz it was like my books and you
know some of the things that I grew up
with like my record player and my guitar
like people could see a lot like could
see a lot into my life which was a
little bit scary but at the same time
really cool to share with my fans